Hi very excited to be here.
So I do a lot of
exploratory data
analysis and a lot of that flow
is built around reading data
into memory.
The first step is
we import some data
before we can transform,
visualize, model it.
And if you're in this room, it
might be in this databases track,
it might be because a
lot of the time that's
not where the data we need
is. In a lot of organizations,
1e work with data that's in a
database, MySQL, PostgreSQL,
snowflake, SQL Server and a
lot of the most exciting data
analyses don't start from
reading a CSV into memory.
They start by hitting
data that's in SQL.
I have a strong belief that
working with a database
should be as easy for
your team as possible.
The last couple of years,
there's been a lot of attention
to how can we build
R packages that
make working with make work
within a company really smooth.
That really helped people
get to the data that
matters for their
team for the team and.
That first kind of
really hit me when
I was in my first data scientist
role at Stack Overflow.
So when I first got in
there, I was the first R user
and I ended up building
an internal package called
sqlstackr that managed
kind of a connecting
and working with the
data in those databases
and every job I've
had since I've
built some similar
iteration onto that,
onto that same template
of creating a database
package that wraps a
database connection.
So now we've opened
sourced it as dbcooper.
So dbcooper is an--
it started as an R
package named after the famous
bandit, the hijacker, DB Cooper.
And I'm excited to share that,
while it started,
as an R package,
Michael Chao has actually
ported it to Python.
So now there's both a
dbcooper R and Python version.
And what they do
is to make it one
step to create a database
specific packages.
So if you're at a
company, Widgets Inc,
you can use dbcooper to create
an internal package, like widgetr
or widgetpy to help
analysts fluidly access
the data in your databases.
Let's talk about the problem
that it's solving. Mostly today,
I'm to be talking from the
perspective of the R
package.
But a lot of these same
problems and solutions
exist in the Python version.
So what's it like to work
with a database from R?
What might you need
to do when you're
analyzing data in a database?
Some common tasks.
You may need to list the tables
that are in the database.
You may want to transform
tables using dplyr.
So dbplyr is a
really powerful package
that lets you work with
a remote table, kind
of as if it were
an in-memory table.
And who here has used dbplyr?
Really it is a really
fun experience, isn't it?
We sometimes can't
just use dbplyr.
We want to run our
custom SQL queries.
So we want to construct
SQL select statements
ourselves and try running them.
And sometimes we need
to execute a command,
like creating a table
or dropping a table.
So I'll give an example
here of how we might
work with the SQL connection.
So this is a database
called lahman.
It's based on the Lahman
baseball statistics data
set, a really phenomenal
collection of tables,
and it comes built
into dbplyr.
So we've got this
lahman db object
that's a SQL connection and.
Let's start with how might
we go about listing tables?
We'd use the dbListTables
function from DBI.
It would get us a vector of
the tables in the database.
If we wanted to work
with a remote table
as if it were a dbplyr
table, we'd
use the tibble function tbl.
On this database, we want to
get one of the tables out of it.
In the case of
the lahman data, we
might be interested in its
table on batting statistics.
If I want to run
a SQL query, I'd
still use the tbl
function, but now I
could use the SQL function to
actually construct that query.
So here I might be
writing a query where
I'm counting the batting
table grouped by player ID
and getting back
some results from it.
And if I want to
execute a command,
I might use the
dbExecute function.
So these four
approaches, they work
they do what they're
supposed to do.
But something really
bothers me about them.
Something is just fundamentally
a little bit harder
to use than I would expect it
to be something is they're not
they're not designed how I would
want to work with this data.
And I really try and figure
out what is bothering me
about these functions.
And I'll say, I
think that let's say
if I load up this database,
what really is bugging
me is that lahman db object.
Like in our environment, we've
got this lahman db object.
It's a SQL connection object.
And I don't know what that is.
It's for me, that's the
wrong level of abstraction.
I want to be working
with individual tables.
I want to be directly
writing SQL queries
and immediately executing them.
I don't necessarily I
don't know how I'm going
to pass this connection around.
It's a clumsy way to
engage with a database.
So that's why I see that
there's a missing puzzle
piece in between DBI for creating
a connection to a database
and dbplyr for transforming
and exploring those tables.
That's where dbcooper comes in.
It turns a database into
an opinionated collection
of functions to let us
explore it really fluidly.
Kind of as if it were
data that were in memory.
DB
Cooper takes--
You only need to do one
function call to set up
dbcooper,
it's dbc init.
You pass it the
connection object
and you give it a prefix.
If you've worked with
a lot of R packages,
you know how useful it can be to have a
shared prefix. dbc init stores
and manages the
connection globally.
It generates a prefixed
function for important tasks
you would do with that database,
and really importantly, it
generates autocomplete friendly
accessors for tables.
So I'll show how
each of those tasks
would be achieved in dbcooper.
Once you've run
dbc init, instead
of doing DB list tables, I would
just do lahman underscore list.
So that prefix that I passed,
it turned into a prefix
for the function.
Lahman list would
return the list of tables
that are in the database.
So lahman, if I want to
access just one table,
I use lahman underscore
TBL so I send in lahman tbl,
then it can pass at
the name of a table.
Get that one back.
If you want to
run a query, I do
lahman underscore query
and pass the SQL.
And if I wanted to execute, I'd
use lahman underscore execute.
So one thing to
notice about this is
it'ss taking the connection
object entirely out
of the picture,
and it's focusing
on opinionated set of
tasks that someone might
want to do with the database.
My favorite feature about
dbcooper is autocomplete.
So instead of so, whenever
I've worked with a database,
it can be hard to remember
what the tables are.
And I get kind of tired of
constantly referring back
to the documentation or
even to a list function
to see what they are.
And I don't like I would maybe
run into typos, et cetera
and it just doesn't
feel anything
like working with
data that's in memory.
So dbcooper creates
one function for each
of the tables in your database
so that you can access
them with autocomplete.
So it's a much more
fluid experience
where I could say where
if I go into a table,
I can just start
typing it and see,
Oh yeah, here are the
tables that I can't remember
exactly what this table
in my database is called,
but I use autocomplete
to help me out.
One thing I like
about that is it
makes something
like a complicated
join much more concise
and much easier to read.
For me, again, it
really means I don't
have to remember that I'm
working with SQL tables.
Using dbplyr
with remote tables
can feel a lot like using
dplyr with local tables.
So I've been showing
examples of the R function.
What Michael Chao
has set up is really
phenomenal, which is dbcooper
py where each of the-- it
has these same syntax for
creating list, table, query
and execute.
But it also takes advantage
of his siuba package.
Siuba is a Python
port of dplyr
that supports both local
pandas data frames and data
and databases.
So here, you can actually see
that we could use the lahman
data and say dot TBL
for the salaries,
and then pipe to count,
but all within Python.
So one thing I think
is great about siuba is
if you're really
familiar with dplyr
and you're just going
over to Python, siuba
is absolutely the way to do it.
And dbcooper in Python is a way
to use that in your databases.
I'm going to show an
example of exploring
a database using dbcooper.
So it's the New York Times COVID
19 database.
Google makes public a large
set of data of databases.
Lets see 239 databases
in Google BigQuery.
So this is a phenomenal
resource because that
means there are 239 packages
you could write wrapping
each of these data sources.
I'm going to show one, which
is the New York Times COVID 19
database.
So we start by creating
the connection.
dbcooper
doesn't help with this.
We create it ourselves
using DBI dbConnect,
really whatever approach
we would generally
use to create a
database connection.
And then all we have to do
with dbcooper is dbc init,
and we'll say we'll
use the prefix covid
so all of our functions
we're going to use to access
this are going to start
with the word covid.
So now that I have
done dbc init, I
could use COVID list
if I want to see, OK,
there are four tables
in this database.
And if I want to
access one of them,
I could say, OK, COVID
underscore US states.
Now I've got this
autocomplete friendly way
to access one of
the tables and we
see data that looks
like it's a time series.
It might separate across
each of the US states.
It's got it's got both a column
for confirmed cases and deaths.
In my understanding, it gets
updated daily so we could build
something on top of this
that unlike a static data set
is going to stay up to date.
And now that I've got it,
I can work with this data
as if it were local.
I can work with it and I
can filter, I can arrange,
I can do visualizations.
So I can let's say we
pipe it through it.
This is actually all
this aggregation,
this filter, this
arrange, this mutate
was all turned into a SQL,
a SQL query, gets run,
gets brought into memory
only when we plot it.
And this thing that I
really like about dbcooper
is I just forget I'm using it.
As soon as you've got these
tables, you kind of just
go right back into
your normal flow.
I never liked when I
worked with SQL databases
that I'd have to
take one step to do
the select and the collect.
And now I'm working in my
traditional exploratory data
analysis flow. Here,
you can basically you can barely
tell where the database ends
and where your exploratory
data analysis begins.
Where dbcooper really shines is in
creating an opinionated package
around a database.
So I'll give an example.
As I said, I first
developed this kind of approach
while I was working
at Stack Overflow.
So it's appropriate
that we set up
a package that wraps a public
Stack Overflow database, which
is one of the BigQuery
public databases is Stack Overflow
questions, answers, tags.
So around this
database we set up
the stack BigQuery
package. This is a package
I put up just as an example of
package that could be created.
We pick the database, now
let's wrap it with a package.
And the way that we'd go about
doing that is three steps.
First, we write database
specific connection code.
So anything in terms of setting
up credentials, etc., that's
going to live
inside this package.
Then critically in the
dot, the dot on load and on
unload functions.
Those are functions that run
every time a package is loaded
or unloaded, we're
going to create
one of those
database connections
and then use dbc init.
So this means that as soon as
somebody loads in this package,
it's going to
populate the package's
namespace with functions that
start with that prefix stack.
Now every database is
different and the ways
that we explore them
are different, too.
So the next step
would be adding
database-specific verbs.
Something that I love
to do with Stack Overflow data
is look at, say, patterns
of trends of tags over time.
I'm really interested
in can I aggregate
at the tag level that
requires joining together
a couple tables in
the database and doing
a little bit of custom logic.
That kind of custom database
specific logic or problem
specific logic or
company-specific logic
is really a good fit for a
package that uses dbcooper
because it's going to mean that
the person using this package
actually does this analysis,
it's going to everything
should be set up for them.
So when you do
library stackbigquery,
now we've got a function
stack underscore
for any of the we've got stack
list, stack table, stack,
execute, stack query and one
of these functions for each
of the table accessors.
So basically by
loading library, it's
as if every table
just got loaded right
into their environment.
So they can use it.
Here's an example of an
analysis that I would do, but.
So here we go.
So here's an example
of an analysis
that I would do, for
instance, of tags over time.
So this is an
aggregation that compares
a couple of technologies like
Python, JavaScript, Java and R
in terms of the percentage of
Stack Overflow questions each
was done by month by
month that are tagged
with this particular language.
So we can notice there's a
use of that summarized tags
function that's
database specific
and then there's just some db,
some dplyr, some ggplot2.
And again really
quickly, you can
forget that you're working
with a database at all.
So we learn from the dbcooper
package is kind of really
two takeaways.
One is don't underestimate
the value of small usability
improvements that
affect you every day.
And second is that
a good database
package lets you forget
about the package entirely.
See, once we've got
this data loaded,
it's really as if we just
had instead of looking
at that one connection object.
And now we're always working
with that connection object.
Now we're just working with
all the tables in the database.
So next time you're working
with a database connection,
it just takes one line.
Try
dbcooper.
I'd love to hear what you think.
Thank you.